good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm just
back from a crazy and beautiful and
exhausting trip to Brazil in support of
cidades de papel and I will talk more
about that later but for now I want to
talk about Greece so Hank as you know I
was the third best economist among all
si students at the Alabama State
Academic Decathlon in 1994 but even a
professional like myself does not know
how the economic crisis in Greece should
or will end so I'm not going to try to
offer solutions today I'm just going to
try to understand the problem and how we
came to a place so desperate that the
news media has created the horrific
compound word grexit so Greece is a
country in southern Europe you know the
Acropolis Socrates Hypatia the movie 300
etc and until 2001 its currency was the
drachma which probably meant handful
because 3,000 years ago a drachma was a
handful of six metal sticks that were
used as currency flash forward a bit to
1832 Greece becomes an independent
nation and brings back the drachma
but then in 2001 Greece joined the
eurozone along with all of these
countries and began using the euro as
its currency the Euro has been great
insofar as it facilitates trade but 19
countries sharing a currency has its
problems like one of the reasons this
crisis has been so confounding is that
Greece's monetary policy how much money
they can print is controlled by the
European Central Bank
but Greece's fiscal policy how much
money they can spend and where they
spend it is mostly controlled by the
Greek government now Greece and other
eurozone countries are supposed to
follow some basic fiscal rules like no
more than three percent annual budget
deficits for instance but many eurozone
countries including Greece have broken
those rules speaking of which since the
mid 1990s the Greek government had been
reporting deficits and debts that were
much lower than the actual deficits and
debts and then every time a new
government got elected they would be
like wow the previous government was not
telling the whole truth about deficits
and then that new government would
proceed to not tell the whole truth
about deficits and then in 2009 a newly
elected government announced that the
budget deficit that year would be
thirteen point nine percent of total
economic output and that the numbers had
been fudged for some previous years how
did it get so bad well that depends on
who you ask some people point out that
Greece's labor costs got much higher
after joining the eurozone they probably
had too much debt to start there was a
huge problem with tax evasion in Greece
and when the 2008 u.s. recession became
global Greece was
affected because two of its biggest
industries are shipping and tourism
neither of which fare particularly well
in recessions now I want to emphasize
that it's not always bad for a
government to run a deficit if that
deficit can be invested in ways that
grow the economy and increase the tax
base it will increase government revenue
it's a virtuous cycle for instance the
United States has a strong economy and
we've been running a deficit quite
consistently for 50 years but Greece's
situation is different they've been able
to borrow money at low interest rates
ever since joining the Euro because
people figured they were a safe bet
right the euro is safe but with these
revelations in 2009 that Greece's
deficits were so high investors started
to get nervous and they started to ask
for higher and higher interest rates in
exchange for loans Greece needed that
money so it had to accept the higher
interest rates which made its deficit
problem worse which made the interest
rates go up that's a vicious cycle okay
so by the spring of 2010 the problem had
become so bad that a younger and more
promising version of myself discussed it
in a blog brother's video also it was so
bad that the European Commission and the
International Monetary Fund came to
Greece's aid with a 110 billion euro
bailout the European Central Bank also
helped out by buying some Greek debt and
giving Greek banks access to capital and
these three institutions came to be
known as the troika now this all may
seem very generous of Europe and the IMF
but one it was a loan not a gift and two
back then the eurozone was feeling
contagion jitters interest rates were
also starting to creep up in Portugal
and Ireland and Spain and there was a
real fear that the whole eurozone might
fall apart and that would be disastrous
for trade would also lead to a big
worldwide recession furthermore most of
Greece's debt was owed to German and
French banks so in a way the governments
of the biggest countries in the euro
zone were lending money to Greece so
that Greece could pay back the banks of
the biggest countries in the eurozone so
in exchange for these loans Greece
agreed to austerity measures basically
they raised taxes and cut pensions and
other benefits and this kind of worked
insofar as Greece did decrease their
budget deficit from 25 billion euro in
2009 to just 5.2 billion euro in 2011
but it also caused the Greek economy to
contract dramatically people have less
money to spend as their pension shrank
and there
as rows and that in turn led to the
failure of businesses and fewer jobs and
as the economy shrank so did tax
revenues because the economy is the
thing that governments tax and in the
end nothing really got better Greece
still didn't have a sustainable economy
so in 2012 the troika loaned them
another 130 billion euro and then over
the last couple years there were some
real signs of life in the Greek economy
and it looked like things were starting
to bottom out but unemployment is still
over 25 percent and I want to emphasize
that economic crises are also
humanitarian crises 30 percent of people
in Greece now live in poverty and almost
one in five doesn't have enough money to
buy food that will meet their daily
nutritional needs the great depression
has been as deep as the United States as
Great Depression and it may not be over
but from a wider European economic
perspective things have gotten a lot
better in the last five years
private European banks on much less
Greek debt than they did in 2010 the
economies of Ireland and Portugal are
much healthier and so it's much less
likely that the Greek economy collapsing
or even Greece exiting the euro would be
catastrophic for the rest of Europe ok
so flash board at the end of last year a
new leftist government is elected in
Greece and they say no more austerity we
can't take it anymore their argument and
many economists would agree with this is
that austerity will never work because
the economy just keeps shrinking and
shrinking and shrinking at least as fast
as the deficit does in response to this
the troika stopped sending loan payments
and then there were a bunch of
negotiations and then the Greek
government put it to a referendum should
we continue with austerity so that we
can get this loan money or should we
just say no and then on July 5th the
Greek people voted overwhelmingly to say
no now technically this was a symbolic
vote because the troika had pulled their
offer off the table on June 30th but
yeah that's how we got to where we are
now without these payments coming into
Greece there is suddenly a very serious
liquidity crisis in Greek banks
basically Greek banks may have only 500
million euro left which is like 45 euro
per person in Greece many ATMs are out
of cash others can only dispense 10 euro
notes because they're out of 20s and if
this continues Greece will be forced to
print some form of alternate currency to
make payments to retirees and government
employees and that would be the
so-called greg's at a Greek exit from
the eurozone and nobody knows quite what
would happen
then I mean what the economic
implications would be but also the
political and legal ones now Hank
normally in a situation like this 25
percent unemployment shrinking economy
liquidity crisis Greece would just print
more money but they can't because
they're part of the eurozone and as
previously noted the European Central
Bank decides how much money to print and
that gets to the root of the problem the
eurozone wants to be a transnational
currency but each country inside of it
answers to their own citizens Germany
doesn't want to print more money it
would be bad for the German economy and
they're not keen on sending more money
to Greece from their perspective it's
not their fault that Greece can't pay
their debts but from a Greek perspective
it's hard to see how that country has
benefited from these so-called bailouts
many Greeks feel that the troika's
bailouts really only bought time for
other European nations and their banks
to distance themselves from Greece's
financial problems Hank this inability
to decide just how unified they should
be is the real existential problem of
the eurozone obviously Hank there's a
lot of blame to go around here but in
the end if you can't listen to the
narratives of others if you can't
construct an idea of the eurozone in
which all members are members of some US
and you can't expect to share a
continent effectively let alone a
currency Hank I'll see you on Friday